yeah hello and welcome to this video
this will be a short video at just an
additional on video to the game murasa
which against telegraph that i did
recently for the modern classics serious
because there was on one very irritating
variation which i didn't really show
properly so i want to want to show this
here quickly on the board because it's
just a pain to enter all these
variations in the in the text on the
text to the video so just go gree flee
to the through the moose if you haven't
seen the whole video yet for this game i
recommend them to watch it it's just
them out of this world game alright so
let's get to the point yeah it was this
check nice da check and um on this move
a kilogram played king he said which is
served the only move however there's the
alternative king to be eight and this is
where the tricky variation occurs why
takes on d7 King takes yeah and in this
position in my video I gave Bishop takes
e8 as winning for white which is true
this is the best move but I didn't
really show properly why ambition is 60
some it's not as strong because it looks
very strong yeah yeah every um yeah
every person who I'm made this remark is
certainly right it looks like a very
strong move y term gives a check and
text the Queen at the same time so at
first you think okay just rinse a queen
but this is not the case um black has a
defense and this is the knight to e cig
and I 25 so weird-looking desperado move
you need to play this simply otherwise
the queen is lost
and what you need to keep in mind black
is two pieces up yeah already it's got
two extra pieces so we can return one
yeah Bishop takes d5 there's not not
much else white needs to take this and
he apply can save himself with the check
at least save himself from getting mated
or losing instantly a check king d to
King be too so the king is also blocking
the rook at the moment yeah so in this
position um now white can take the rook
with check and this is probably am also
advisable don't think down there's any
serious alternative he needs to take
this it's a check after all and now
black also has only got one movement
this is going to deform in this way like
make sure that the Queen's come off and
you have a look at this position or
black ISM an exchange down he's got two
bishops against um yeah rook end bishop
he's an exchange down he's got one part
for the exchange five points against for
so from material point of view black is
some may be slightly worse the problem
of this position is more for black that
his king is still in the middle and yeah
he's got everything on the back rank um
so probably this position is some it's
better for white it's so it's rather
clear advantage really but it's not
winning outright this Bishop takes eh in
this position we should take c 8 which i
gave in the in the original video is
simply it's a mate yeah it's made at the
end even or winning winning the house so
this oops I didn't want to do that so if
you look let's go to that to the endgame
so once again okay so this wouldn't have
been worse for white or anything wide
still
pretty clear advantage but it's not
winning outright I should have shown
this of course because we should be six
is such an obvious move and it's not bad
as we see here here wider probably
should play c3 trying to break this this
pawn ziam and black probably che it
takes and takes him and his hope is to
get some endgame that you can hold its
it's difficult it's difficult for black
this pawn is not really dangerous and
yeah white has some centralized King and
an active position so black will have a
hard time drawing this for sure but this
is also why after this why she played
King g7 here and not King yet because
well the line that that I gave in the
first video is completely crushing at
this end game is probably also close to
being lost so King is seven was the far
better choice and the game it loses but
it sets a White's problems and King he
aged really Bishop d7 which would be six
is very easy to see a bishop c8 the
alternative which is probably stronger
even it's also something that Morrow
probably would have found him rather
easily so um yeah just video just serves
us in addition to to the real one about
this game which again is heavily
recommended if you didn't watch it
already yeah thanks and I'll be back
soon with the yeah longer video